welcome back to las vegas now kennel
health the sponsors of this next segment
are focused on value based over volume
based health care so let's welcome cmo
of kennel health rick sanchez to explain
the benefits of this method welcome
lucky how are you i'm good how are you
i'm fantastic all right so let me take
you through this yeah please explain
what value based over
version volume being so let's suppose
rocky goes out tomorrow and eats too
much boom bang
right
he's already done you've
done that
yeah and then what happens is you get
sick right so you go to the doctor and
the doctor says that'll be fifty dollars
and then the next day you eat boom bag
again and the doctor says that'll be
fifty dollars and you keep getting sick
now the third day let's suppose you go
and you hurt your knee or your ankle or
something like that and the doctor
charges you another 50 and deep down
he's incentivized for you to go get sick
because every time you get sick
you pay him right that's called
transactional medicine that's called
he's counting on me to get sick exactly
that's that's what we have in america
right now it's called volume-based
medicine
every time you looking at me right now
gets sick you gotta go to the doctor and
you got to pay to get well and the
doctor deep down he doesn't want you to
be sick most doctors are good people
right but deep down he knows yeah this
guy keeps breaking his ankle i keep
making more money so let's do this let's
throw out transactional medicine throw
out volume volume-based medicine which
is what we have right now and replace it
with the kano model so cannel health
believes that we need
value-based medicine and value-based
medicine is this
i only pay you dr rocky if you who are
my doctor keep me healthy
so if i get sad because i ate too much
boom bust
whatever if i
if i if you allow me to get sick
you make less money
so the whole idea is to incentivize
the doctors so that patients remain
healthy right right that makes sense it
makes complete sense it's prevention
right it's prevention and it's actual
genuine care about the person in your
office as well right about the patient
and you know how we do that how cr a
relationship
you know about relationships right
with the guy who owns the restaurant
probably oh my gosh so now
so here's what we do we create
relationships with our patients what we
do is we make sure that the patient is
constantly coming in to see us now he's
calling us she is calling us that we're
calling them if they need medications we
use one of our vans and we take him to
his house or her house we make sure
they're perfectly healthy all the time
because we don't want them to suddenly
get sick and go to the emergency room
right by the way you know when you go to
the emergency room they're going to
charge you 800 for an aspirin
so it's better to keep costs down by
having a relationship with your doctor
so what do we do
we have zumba we have birthday parties
we have wellness we invite our patients
to just come to spend the day with us
and while without they're there we check
their vitals we check their heart we
check their blood we check their uh
oxygen levels we basically make sure
that they're not going to get sick
because the more people we keep healthy
the more money we make isn't that crazy
that is great that's a great method the
kennel model yeah the candle model
better than boom boo do or whatever so
silly thank you no we appreciate you
bringing that to the community kennel
health it's on east tropicana avenue and
there's several locations though right
yeah give us a call yeah we'd love to
have you come by and we'll give them a
tour absolutely the number is
702-848-2875